how are you i'm doing excellent i'm
talking about james bond now this is a
great day um so i i'm definitely curious
when you were making spectre did you
have any inclination that you were gonna
be such a big part of that film and this
film
no i didn't know at the end of spectre
that i
you know that i would come back
um
because i really thought that it was
daniel's last film
so when they called me you know it was
five years after
which is quite some time i was uh
i was happy i mean first i was very very
happy and uh
and
and even more because i had the the
possibility to explore
the character
more
and develop
her
her
her her personality
sure
completely what the thing what does it
actually mean to you because you're the
first of james bond's love interests to
have a prominent role in two james bond
films
so i'm just curious what that means to
you
uh
i mean it means it means that
the world has changed
that
the franchise
has changed as well
and uh it's
i think i mean it's not i mean it is
thanks to daniel because he wanted to
first of all he did what he did with his
character you know he really changed
it he changed him and he made him more
human
and
he gave him
he gave him depth and i think that he
wanted to do the same thing with the the
female
uh roles and it's not only my part but
even la chana lynch plays a
uh double o seven
so he wanted to have
more interesting female characters and
that is something
[Music]
you know that i that i that i'm really
happy about
oh i am i am too sorry yeah yeah
no and and and and i think that daniel
also um
is um
a feminist and uh
and uh and that you could like you you
can really feel it in the film i mean
my character
um has no like she's not
seen through a
you know a men
perspective she doesn't wear the sexy
bathing suit or
you know she doesn't uh she doesn't have
the sexy dress i mean she's not
sexualized this time and this is
something
i think
very new you know for the for the
franchise and we needed to have
a great uh
ex exam we needed to have like great
examples of of strong women
and um
[Music]
and uh yeah it's it's uh
it's uh it's i'm really really pleased
about it
i
same with same with me my last question
for you i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of movies what
do you think might surprise people to
learn about the making of no time to die
um
it's um
uh
it's sometimes we think that when we see
those big films we think that it's like
that are
that are easy to make in a way
you know or the the the stunts or the
the
and actually what i've always like uh
found
incredible
in when i was on set as an actor is that
you really do everything in a way you
know it's it's it's
it it's a way it's it's
artisanal artisanal artisanal you know
it's like it's really uh
i mean all the details
you know are just been thought of and
and uh it's such a
you have no idea i think how difficult
it is to make a film
and that is always something that
it strikes it strikes me you know yeah
i'm i'm amazed by how like
the the team effort you know how can
like everybody can just really give like
their best and how we just it's it's
really a collaboration
and uh and also like the the
yeah it's not only the acting who's
difficult it's all the technical aspects
and on on a film like james bond i mean
even more
even more
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats i wish you nothing
but the best thank you so much for your
time
thank you